finding the right partner it comes down
to do I need a partner and what do I
need a partner for typically somebody
either has to have expertise you don't
have time you don't have or money you
don't have if this person doesn't have
one of those three things that you don't
have you shouldn't work with them
because there's no point and this is
honestly the number one mistake that
most people make is they're like you
like guitars I like guitars we're
friends we should totally do this but
you share all of the same things which
means one of you is irrelevant which
will eventually create conflict every
single business needs an accountant it
doesn't mean you need to partner with
account it means you just need an
accountant there are functions that must
happen within a business it doesn't mean
you necessarily need a partner and so
it's really just a balance of like what
does the business need and how rare is
that skill and what am I willing to pay
for it it's going to come down to time
knowledge or money